it's just more and more
nonsense by an out-of-control government
that has now decided
that the very laws that we live by
the constitution no longer applies to
them that's what they think now of
course we did have two sham impeachments
of orange man uh but they think these
people think that uh they don't have to
listen to the constitution they don't
have to listen to laws or anything else
uh so here is karine jean-pierre again
she is the temporary i suppose
replacement for jen saki who was out
because of covet even though she was
vaccinated uh basically saying that uh
we're gonna go ahead and keep forcing
businesses to vaccinate people
regardless of whether it's legal or not
or what the courts say we know the
vaccine requirements work
uh and we're going to continue to push
that you know we're going to make sure
that we get as many people vaccinated
it is it is uh it is so important to get
this pandemic behind us and to get the
economy going and so that's i mean
that's going to continue to be our
message is to to to tell anyone that
we're working with whether it's a
democrat or republican that this is how
we have to move forward uh to make sure
that we get out of the situation that
we're in to get out this pandemic again
we still have 1300 people a day
approximately 1 300 people a day dying
of covet that is that we should not that
should not be the number that we're
looking at um and we believe
that in order to get this pandemic
behind us we get we need to get more
people vaccinated and this is a way
to do that and we see vaccination
requirements work
and and also it's important to keep
people safe in their workplace
that should be you know i should be
mission critical in making sure that
that happens uh and so we're gonna you
know we feel confident about the the
legal component of this uh the
department of labor have the has the
authority uh to move forward uh in
making sure that they keep the workplace
safe
and so uh yeah we have to make sure that
we get this pandemic behind us
the department of labor has the
authority no they don't like these
people are just terrible i have to say
she's slightly more likable than saki
saki is just absolutely terrible this
lady she's a little bit better i would
suppose in the likability but again
she's just a [ __ ] artist no notice
she never said anything about the
constitution she never said anything
about the bible rights she never said
anything about individual rights or just
your decision to make a medical uh
decision for yourself they just don't
care now she did say 1300 people a day
okay so let me just assume for a second
i'll go out on the assumption and say
she's not flat out lying about that
let's just say 1 300 people are dying a
day now we have about 340 million or so
people in america people die of all
sorts of things can we get a number
maybe on how many people die of uh
getting hit by a car give me give me
something on how many people die of
different things like should we not
allow people in cars like what what are
we really talking about also could i get
some numbers like related to
co-morbidity as on those people were
they all 87 years old and seriously fat
and had other diseases like we should
know about some of this stuff but they
don't care what she really really wants
is the government the federal government
to just ram through decisions
and not care what the courts say so one
of the courts decided that this is not
constitutional you can't just force
companies to do that again really just
putting aside partisan stuff putting
aside everything really think how
bananas it would be if after lunch where
as i already said we're having jersey
mike's it's not the healthiest lunch but
i was letting you guys have it today uh
if i grabbed one of these people and
took them to cvs and forced a stranger
to inject them with something so that
they could continue to work for me would
that be sensible i don't think that
would be sensible we've got some
information here 3 thousand
seven hundred people die from car wrecks
every day that's according to the
association for safe international road
travel one of my favorite organizations
three thousand seven hundred people die
a day should we get the roads the cars
off the roads i mean what what are we
really
really talking about here they just want
more power and and now we got a scary
video if you didn't think that was kind
of scary and it is kind of scary the
idea that the federal government thinks
it can just run over the courts that's
kind of scary in one way but they talk
in such a way that makes it sound
like they're actually doing something
legit
even though it's not you get my point
but if you thought that was sort of
scary or like a little weird or whatever
she's got nice hair so maybe she's not
so bad um here's the pfizer ceo his
name's albert borla this video just
broke in the last like 20 minutes before
we started
talking about misinformation related to
covid and what we should do
with the people who share
misinformation
but there is a very small part
of professionals which they circulate on
purpose misinformation
so that they will mislead
those that they have concerns
those people are criminals they're not
bad people they're criminals because
they literally cost them
millions of lives
and then should be treated as criminals
as well those who have done that
they should be treated as criminals uh
they've cost millions of lives
misinformation related to covet has cost
millions lives we have no evidence that
that's true but if you want to talk
about misinformation related to covert
we should talk about anthony fauci we
should talk about him lying under oath
to congress about mrnas we should talk
about how he told his friends that they
could go on vacation and not worry about
masks because you touch your face more
with masks we should talk about two
weeks to flatten the curve have they
lied about that i mean all of the stuff
lockdowns work there's no evidence that
lockdowns work like misinformation
you're right man and if you want to
criminalize that stuff and by the way
i'm pretty sure that the ceo of pfizer
doesn't get to decide who is a criminal
and what should happen to criminals at
least not yet even though pfizer does
sponsor all of our mainstream media you
may remember we played that compilation
a couple weeks ago now i was thinking
there was a word as i was watching that
guys that uh i wanted to say to uh that
fellow there that ceo of pfizer but i
can't say it because if i say it we get
demonetized so i just wanna i'm just
gonna read my notes here uh for just a
second and uh
okay